Bitte schön.
Hallo. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ali Osman Aydogan.
Ich bin auch dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufmerkspräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Gerne. Bitte schön.
Ich werde erst mal ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Stelle, dann kommen wir sofort Ihrer Besprache.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Schmidt.
Schmidt?
Pepka Schmidt.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname und Nachname leisten, wo Sie das haben?
Pewee Paula, Ewe Emil, Ewe Theodor, Erlir Richard, Awe Anton.
Okay, Nachname?
Schmidt.
SV Siegfried, CV Caesar, Awe Heinrich, M. W. Mater, Ewe Ida, D. V. Dora, C. V. Theodor.
Okay, danke schön, Herr Schmidt. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin eine Frau.
Ah, sorry.
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1970, am 3. Mai.
Wie viel wiegen Sie? Wie sind Sie?
Wie viele Spiegel?
Ja.
Ungefähr 55 Kilogramm.
55 Kilogramm. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 68 Kilogramm.
Okay, Frau Schmidt, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich komme mal zu Ihnen, weil ich seit ungefähr 3 Monaten zunehmend müde bin und sehr schwach bin.
Das macht mir ein bisschen Sorgen.
Seit 3 Monaten sind Sie müde und schwach.
Also, haben Sie andere Bescheid?
Ich habe kippelt in den Beinen manchmal.
Manchmal kippelt es in den Beinen.
Ich konnte akustisch nicht gehören.
Ich habe kippelt in den Beinen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Konzentration?
Ja, es geht eigentlich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Verstoffung?
Was habe ich?
Verstoffung.
Manchmal.
Was meinen Sie manchmal?
Ab und zu.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, ungefähr 3 Kilogramm.
3 Kilogramm.
In welcher Zeitraum?
Ja, so 3 Monate, ungefähr.
Haben Sie zugenommen oder abgenommen?
Abgenommen.
Also, leiden Sie unter Haarausfall?
Nein.
Also, wie sonst?
Üblich.
Ich habe immer Haarausfall.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht schlimmer geworden.
Aber normal.
Ist es nicht schlimmer geworden?
Okay.
Also, schützen Sie vermerkt?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Also, leiden Sie unter Atemnot?
Ja, wenn ich mich belaste schon.
Bei Belastung?
Atemnot.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen mehr geworden.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine heilere Stimme?
Nein, wie immer.
Wie immer.
Okay.
Also, hat sich Ihre Verstoffung verändert in der letzten Zeit?
Stuhlgang verändert in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, ich bin schon in der Pause.
Ah, sorry.
Also, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Kribbelgefühl hat in Beinen?
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kraftverlust?
Ja.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen mehr.
Haben Sie Kraftverlust?
Kraftverlust?
Ja, Kraftverlust.
Es geht.
Also eigentlich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ihre Beine schwelmend?
Nein.
Haben Sie eine Schmetze?
Anbei?
Ja, ich bin kribbel.
Okay, nur kribbel.
Haben Sie, okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich bin kribbel.
Haben Sie Stelpostmachschweiß oder Kaltschweiß?
Nein.
Ich fühle mich auch nicht krank.
Ich bin nur sehr erschöpft, müde, schwach.
Ich habe manchmal Schwindel.
Also, was meinen Sie manchmal?
Einmal am Tag oder alle zwei Tage.
Okay, haben Sie unter Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Auch nicht mehr.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen?
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit,
haben Sie Schwierigkeiten durchzuschlafen
oder einzuschlafen?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit, weil die Beine kribbeln.
Wegen kribbeln können Sie nicht gut schlafen.
Ja, das kribbelt.
Manchmal kribbelt das sehr stark,
dass ich den aufwachen muss.
Dann kann ich nicht wieder einschlafen.
Okay.
Ich entschuldige mich vor euch mit,
dass ich gleichzeitig notiere und hören,
Sie hören, deswegen ist aber ein bisschen lang.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ein bisschen vermindert, aber...
Ein bisschen ver.
Ich habe wenig Appetit.
Wenig.
Wenig Appetit, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Haben Sie Fragen?
Wie bitte?
Also ich würde gerne,
ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen über,
also zu Ihrer Vorgestellung stellen.
Ja.
Okay.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe Blutdruck und Diabetes.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruckdruck?
Seit schon 15 Jahren jetzt.
15 Jahre.
Das ist bei uns familiär.
Meine Eltern haben das auch.
Okay.
Was haben Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme Lübchenmedikamente ein.
Welche Medikamente kennen Sie?
Ich nehme Ranipril ein und Amlodipine ein.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Ja.
Beide.
Beide einmal morgen?
Genau.
Seit wann haben Sie Diabetes?
Morgen und Abend.
Beide, oder?
Beide morgen und Abend.
Seit wann haben Sie Unverkrankheit?
Seit um 14 Jahren.
14 Jahre.
10 Jahre.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Das ist bei mir später aufgetreten.
Ich nehme auch Insulin ein.
Und Metformin.
Okay.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Metformin nehme ich 1000 Leinen morgen und abends.
Und ich soll abends 30 Einheiten
von Insulin nehmen.
Und ich habe den
irgendwie so, aber nicht gefallen.
War es komplikant, komplikationslos?
Nein bitte.
War es komplikationslos?
Ja, ja klar.
Alles ok.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente außerhalb Ram, Kri, Amlogipin um sie hin oder mit Romin?
Normalerweise nehme ich keine weitere Medikation rein.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unterkriegigkeit?
Nicht besser.
Nicht pecker.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihre Eltern Bluthoftdruck hat.
Meine Mutter hat auch Diabetes.
Meine Mutter hat auch Diabetes und Vater nur Bluthoftdruck.
Genau, und der Kalastrin wird erhöhen, glaube ich, auch.
Ok.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch alle?
Meine Eltern leben noch, sind alt, leben noch.
Ok, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelte.
Einzelte? Ok.
Frau Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Wie können Sie Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr selten.
Also vielleicht 2-mal oder 3-mal im Jahr.
2-mal oder 3-mal im Jahr.
Also nehmen Sie nächste Frage nicht mehr, bitte.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Rogen?
Nein.
Frau Schmidt, sind Sie voll geimpft gegen die Kipperkrankheiten und Corona?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Haben Sie einen Treibensichupport?
Weniger, weniger.
Ich versuche, aber Erfahrung zu spazieren gegen so etwas in der Hand.
Ok, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, dies Jahr noch nicht.
Frau Schmidt, ich hatte etwas vergessen.
Ich möchte zurück zu Ihrer Beschwerden kommen.
Waren Sie schon mal bei den Haushalts?
Nein, den Haushalts habe ich erst Anfang des Jahres, als ich mir die Blutkontrolle hatte.
Ich muss eigentlich wieder dahin, aber ich habe es noch nicht geschafft.
Ich gehe alle 3 Monate zum Hausarzt und lasse mir die Zuckerwerte kontrollieren.
Aber ich weiß, die letzten 3 Monate war ich nicht da gewesen.
Frau Schmidt, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Verkäuferin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Frau Schmidt, ich habe alle für mich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie etwas hinzufügen oder Fragen an mich?
Ich habe Fragen, muss ich heute hier bleiben?
Oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen.
Ich muss Sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen,
dann benutzt abnehmen und dann vielleicht ein paar Maßnahmen duschen.
Nach der Ergänzung.
Was für Maßnahmen?
Ich schreibe Ihnen eine EKG.
Und machen wir einen Röntgen.
Warum?
Zum Beispiel können wir einen Röntgen machen.
Wie meinst du das Beispiel?
Für die Beine.
Meinen Sie das gebrochen?
Ich denke nicht, aber wir müssen das ausschließen.
Beide Beine, aber ich bin nicht gefallen.
Okay.
Also nehmen Sie einen Platz im Watterraum und ich rufe Sie gleich an.
Okay, dann warum Sie denn das Stimme sagen könnten?
Also machen Sie sich kein Röntgen.
Ich habe schon gesagt, ich kann jetzt nur wenig sagen.
Nach der Ergebnisse können wir, kann ich mehr sagen.
Okay, soll ich dann starten?
Ja, ich rufe Sie gleich an.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe Fragen.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie in den letzten 3 Monaten unter depressive oder gedrückte Stimmung?
Eigentlich nicht wirklich. Es geht mir normalerweise ganz gut.
Haben Sie Verminderung des Antriebs oder Interessenverlust?
Nein, eigentlich auch nicht.
Okay, danke für die Antwort.
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ihr Blutzucker gemessen oder messen lassen?
Ja klar, ich messen das tätig.
Wie weit war das?
Das war so okay, so wie immer eigentlich.
Aber ich bin selten über 200.
Okay.
Ja, eine Frage.
Haben Sie Ihren Beinen Wunde bemerkt?
Nein, das wird auch kontrolliert normalerweise.
Danke.
Bitte schön, Herr Gussade.
Seht Sie gestresst?
Ich arbeite als Verkäuferin, immer gestresst.
Ich habe immer schwierige Kunden.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit Blassehaut bemerkt.
Was erhnen Sie sich tätig?
Ich koche selber.
Ich versuche mich gesund zu ernähren.
Es geht so gut.
Zum Beispiel, Italian oder vegan.
Ich esse nicht so viel Fleisch, aber ich esse gerne Hühnchen.
Manchmal auch gehacktes.
Ich esse Gemüse und versuche mich gesund zu ernähren.
Wir haben unter den Beinen Kribbel gefüllt.
Genau wie ich.
Das ist das Kribbel.
Wenn ich die bewege, muss ich kurz aufstehen.
Dann ist das besser.
Manchmal fühlen sich auch kalt an.
Manchmal brennen die auch.
Das ist ein komisches Gefühl.
Sie haben gesagt, bei der Belastung Luftnot.
Ich bin kurz atmig.
Ich kann nicht richtig durchatmen.
Wenn ich mit dem Fahrer zur Arbeit fahre,
merke ich, dass ich nicht mehr so belastbar bin.
Ich muss 3 km fahren zu meiner Arbeit.
Normalerweise habe ich das immer gut.
Aber in der letzten Zeit bin ich sehr schnell aus der Puste.
Können Sie sich die Genaubischeiben verhalten?
Ich habe eigentlich normalen Stuhlgang, aber manchmal auch Verstopfung.
Keine Durchfall?
Kein Durchfall.
Ich habe auch kein Blut gemerkt.
Haben Sie ein Vitamin Medikament?
Nein.
Ich nehme nur die 4 Medikamente ein, die ich genannt habe.
Ich habe ein Blutbild im Januar.
Im Januar.
Ich habe ein Blutbild und eine Zucker- und Nierenwerte kontrolliert.
Ich habe ein 3-Monats-Programm.
Das war okay.
Ich habe keine Fragen zu sagen.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Haben Sie in Ihren Beinen Haar aufgemacht?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Haben Sie in Ihren Beinen Haar ausgemacht?
Nein.
Nicht mehr als sonst.
Danke.
Alles klar.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich?
Ich bin gern.
Frau Schimmitz ist 54 Jahre alt.
1,68 m groß und 55 kg schwer.
Frau Schimmitz hat sich heute seit 3 Monaten bestehend
von Müdigkeit und Schwachheit.
Schwachheit.
Müdigkeit und Schwachheit.
Sie berichtete, dass sie Ab- und Abstattung hat
in dieser 3 Monate.
Außerdem klagte sie über Parastasy an beiden Beinen
und schwindelte einmal am Tag.
Vertigo.
Bilateralen und extremitäten Parastasy und Vertigo.
Einmal am Tag.
Außerdem klagte sie über die Dispene bei der Belastung.
Die Frage nach Schwellung, Kraftverlust,
Fieber, Überkeit, wurden verneint.
Indervegetative Analyse leidet unter Schlagstörungen
wegen Parastasy und leidet unter Appetitlosigkeit.
Sie leidet unter Appetitlosigkeit.
Und Asylas.
In Appetit.
Nicht Appetitlosigkeit, sondern in Appetit.
Appetitlosigkeit bedeutet in Appetit.
Okay.
Bekannte Vorerkrankungen sind arterialer Hypertonin seit 15 Jahren
und Jabetis Melutus seit 10 Jahren.
Welcher Typ?
Also ich habe das leider nicht gefragt.
Bei der Untersuchung kann ich das zeigen.
Das ist wichtig, oder?
Das müssen Sie klaren.
Ja, stimmt.
Typ 1 oder Typ 2, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ja, okay.
Bei der Untersuchung prägen.
Das prägen.
Dagegen nimmt er Ramikri 5 mg 2 Mal am Tag
und Amnodikrin 5 mg 2 Mal am Tag
und Metformin 1 mg 2 Mal am Tag
und Insulin 30 Einhelligkeiten.
Einheiten.
Einheiten am Abend.
Vor 19 Jahren wurde eine Handgelenk-Opere genommen
und in der Kindheit wurde eine Appendoktemie vorgenommen.
Er hat keine Allergie und Unterrichtigkeit.
In der Familienanmenese zeigten sich beim Vater
arterielle Hypertonin und Hyperlipidinin.
Bei der Mutter diabetes mellitus und arterielle Hypertonin.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Sie hat keine Geschwister.
Sie ist nicht raucherin.
Sie trinkt 2-3 Mal Alkohol im Jahr.
Also Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sozial an einem Nestig ist sie verkäuferin
und geschieden.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Außer, denn sie ist vollgeimpft wegen Kinderkrankheiten
und Corona.
Sie treibt nicht Sport.
Sie war in letzter Zeit nicht im Ausland.
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf
eine hypothyrosik differenzial Diagnostik.
Sie haben gesagt, sie hat nicht gelogen.
Ja, stimmt.
Passt doch, wenn ich so mit hypothyriose zusammen?
Ja, also Gewichtstilus spricht gegen hypothyriose.
Wie kann ich sagen, diese Beschwerden sagt mir nicht so viel.
Sie haben gesagt, sie ist müde.
Sie ist erschöpft.
Sie hat Schwöpfung.
Sie ist kurzatmisch.
Sie ist blass.
Woran lässt man denken?
Ich wiederhole.
Kurzatmigkeit, Erschöpfung, Schwöpfung.
Blässe, das reicht schon aus.
Wenn Sie jemanden haben, der sagt, ich bin blass geworden.
Wissen Sie, was blass bedeutet?
Ja, eigentlich nicht genau.
Blass, wenn die Haut etwas heller ist.
Okay, ich kann sagen, eine nie.
Das wäre eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Das passt besser als hypothyriose.
Ja, ich trug es.
Vielleicht können wir das als Arbeitsdiagnose nehmen.
Passt Ihnen das?
Ist das okay so?
Oder habe ich das falsch gesagt?
Ja, es ist okay.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Was machen Sie für Diagnose?
Für Diagnostik.
Ich habe die Körper untersucht.
Ich gucke die Winterhaut.
Vielleicht beobachte ich
Diagnose an die Liebe.
Ich beobachte die Nage.
Sie machen eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Die Nägel gucken Sie an, die Brüche sind.
Die Wellen sind zum Beispiel.
Die Bindehauten gucken das Ganze den ganzen Körper an.
Die Kunde gucken sich an, ob die Blässe ist.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Ich nehme Blutab.
Zum Beispiel Blutbild.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich nehme Hemoglobin-Werte.
Ich nehme auch Verwittern.
Ich gucke noch B12.
Ich nehme Polsäure.
Polsäure.
Sie haben Transfarihen gesagt.
Transfarihen Rettigungen.
Sie können erst mal gucken, ob eine Anämie vorliegt.
Das reicht, wenn Sie ein normales Blutbild abnehmen.
Vielleicht zusätzlich Ferritin und Reisen abnehmen.
Wenn Sie merken, der Hemoglobin-Wert ist niedrig,
können Sie das nachgestimmen.
Warum macht man das?
Das ist ein Problem.
Es reicht nicht mehr.
Das heißt erst mal, December
soll heute das Blutbild abnehmen.
Dann machen Sie noch downstairs
Insuffiziell ist es im Rahmen des Diabetes Minitus.
Das müssen Sie mit abnehmen auf jeden Fall.
Entzündungswerte würde ich auch abnehmen, CHP.
Vielleicht hat Sie ein Tumor.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Also, meinen Sie Lecumie?
Kann auch sein.
Da reicht aber meistens ein normales Blutbild aus.
Um zu gucken, wie die Verteilung, Leukozytin, Lymphozytin, Erdrozytin.
Das reicht normalerweise aus.
Aber Sie können noch ein großes Blutbild machen.
Dann können Sie noch mal sehen, ob es Blasten gibt oder keine Blasten gibt.
Sie können das EKG gucken.
Ist die Tachikart oder nicht Tachikart?
Meistens, wenn die Patienten einen sehr niedrigen HW haben,
haben die schon sehr hohe Erzfrequenz.
Die sind über 90, manchmal über 100.
Wenn Sie eine Anämie haben, eine hohe Anämie,
dann wissen Sie noch gar nicht, wie der Hemmbogelbien-Wert aussieht.
Ultraschall können Sie machen.
Wenn Sie gucken, ob sie vielleicht irgendwo Metastasen hat,
ob sie Feierfüssigkeit hat, ob sie ein großes Hemmatom irgendwo hat.
Intra-Abdominär kann man das auch sehen.
Vielleicht ist da eine Blutung irgendwo, die wenig merken oder die die Patienten nicht bemerkt hat.
Das können Sie alles in der Notaufnahme machen.
Wenn Sie weitere Diagnostik sagen, wenn man sich eine Anämie bestätigt,
im Labor sehen Sie, dass eine Anämie vorliegt.
Was machen Sie dann für Diagnostik?
Das kann man noch machen.
Oder was sollte man machen?
Für Diagnostik.
Für Diagnose einer Anämie.
Warum man eine Anämie hat?
Sie ist eine Frau.
Können wir die Blutung fragen?
Man kann eine Magenspiegel machen, eine Darmspiegel machen.
Man kann Computertomographie des Torachs des Abdomens machen.
Es gibt eine Reihe von Sachen, die wir machen schon.
Man kann bis zur Nochenmarksbiopsy gehen und um eine Anämie abzuklären.
Aber das macht man alles stationär.
Ich habe nur ein bisschen aufgezählt,
was man für eine Anämiediagnostik alles machen kann.
Richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Ich denke, wir haben die Diagnose-Anämie.
Manche Patienten haben tatsächlich,
auch wenn sie keinen Diabetes haben,
Tribbel in den Beinen oder kalte Hände, kalte Füße,
das kann auch mal für eine Anämie ein Zeichen sein.
Falls wir hier Hematologen haben im Raum,
Sie können gerne etwas dazu sagen.
Vielleicht wissen Sie mehr als ich.
Okay.
Herr Gündes, wir sind ja super.
Noch mal.
Wir sind total nicht.
Wir haben noch eine andere Anämie,
die wir in der Diabetes haben.
Aber wir haben noch eine andere Anämie.
Wir haben noch eine andere Anämie, die wir in der Diabetes haben.
schreiben ist es nicht oder ist es nicht oder
Motive Sklerose würde ich nicht schreiben
ich würde eher sagen Restless Lex syndrome
Ja aber keine Schmerzen, dass es
Restless Lex syndrome gibt
Stimmt haben sie recht, aber es kann auch im Rahmen einer Polyneuropathie
sein im Rahmen des Diabetes mellitus geht auch
Ja, Diabetes mellitus mit Polyneuropathie
z.B.
Polyneuropathie heißt Motivizipieros, Herr Schöne
Nein
Nein, okay
Okay, deswegen ist es etwas anderes
Erster Schipri, Zolumbia, Arsastansars
Zagın, z.B. Periphera, Motivische,
Duschbrüchstörung, Kontrollieren oder Unterzuchern lassen
Stationär auf jeden Fall würde ich auf jeden Fall
GPS chirurgisch und neurologisch kontrollieren lassen
Okay, auf jeden Fall, richtig
Ich habe eine Frage
Sie haben gesagt
Sie haben gesagt, Dispne, aber kurzartigkeit
Deswegen
Therapie, Hodja
Therapie erstmal Diagnose finden
Meistens ist es eine Eisenmangel-Anämie
Haben Frauen sehr häufig
Aber man muss auch ein Tumor ausschließen
Bei einer Anämie
Deswegen muss man die Ursache finden
Vielleicht ist eine Vitamin B12-Mangel-Anämie
Vielleicht eine Vorsor-Anämie
Man kann auch Blussausgüch machen
Und dann muss man je nach Ursache
Vielleicht hat eine Leuchemie
Das wissen wir nicht
Aber sie hat wahrscheinlich eine Anämie
Als Diagnose
Und dann müssen wir gucken
Wenn es eine Eisenmangel-Anämie ist
Eisen ihr geben
Eisen Substitution
Und wenn es Vitamin B12 ist
Vitamin B12, dann muss man gucken
Warum sie eine Vitamin B12-Mangel hat
Wenn es ein Tumor ist
Wenn sie eine Blutung hat
Die Blutung stillen
Da gibt es verschiedene Versionen
Aber meistens ist es eine Eisenmangel-Anämie
War es schwierig oder?
Nein, nicht schwierig
War das falsch?
Das ist eine neurologische Symptome
Neurologe
Nein, nicht aber
Also ich glaube diese neurologischen Symptome
Konzentriert sich sehr
Hat sie aber nicht
Ja, nicht
Aber die Parenz hat ja auch nicht
Funikulore Neurologe
Neurologe
Bezüge Mangl-Anämie
Eine Neurologische
Stimmt
Hab ich jetzt nicht dran gedacht, stimmt
Okay
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Bei denen müssen wir
Herzrasen fragen, aber nicht gefragt
Und Hautchlorot
Ja
Hat sich die Haut verändert?
Was?
Ist sie blass geworden, ist sie geld geworden?
Ja
Das müssen wir noch fragen, alle aus dem
Ja stimmt
Ja
Okay
Aber ich habe keine Verdacht mehr
Deswegen
Ich bin ein bisschen verwirkt
Was soll ich fragen?
Also
Wenn ich am Anfang
Anämie oder
Ja
Anämie denke
Dann kann ich
Fragen
Aber erstmal hatte ich
Eine
Hypothyrosis
Auf der Seite
Man muss manchmal überlegen ob man die Verdacht
Diagnose ändert
Im Laufe der Anämie
Ja
Ich habe eine Frage
Am Anfang
Der Patient
Hat gesagt
Am 3. Mai
Das heißt
Morgen
Geburtstag
Deswegen
Nein
Danke schön
Mai
Vor einem Monat
Ja
Wir haben Juni
Aber danke schön
Wollen Sie mir Glück wünschen?
Danke schön
Ich habe noch eine Frage